mesdames et messieurs mes chers
concitoyens à la suite du conseil de
défense sanitaire qui s'est tenue ce
matin sous l'autorité du président de la
république je veux ce soir partager avec
vous un nouveau point de situation sur
l'évolution de l'épidémie qui frappe
notre pays et faire un bilan des mesures
que je vous avais annoncé le 27 décembre
dernier que nous avons mises en place
pour une durée initiale de trois
semaines qui s'achève donc dimanche
prochain je veux aussi vous dire ce que
sont les évolutions encourageantes qui
commence à se dessiner et sans rien
ignorer des tensions qui s'exercent
encore sur notre système de santé vous
préciser le calendrier dans lequel nous
pourrons courant février élevé la
plupart des restrictions prises pour
freiner l'épidémie à la faveur du
nouveau pass vaccinale qui entrera en
vigueur lundi prochain la france comme
tous les autres pays européens est
frappé depuis maintenant près de deux
mois par une vague d'une ampleur
exceptionnelle
exceptionnel parce qu'elle est alimentée
par le cumul de variants delta et aux
microbes qui se sont non seulement
succéder mais en fait additionnez depuis
la fin de l'année dernière
exceptionnelle surtout en raison de
l'extrême contagiosité du variant mikron
dont on sait qu'il a déjà touché plus de
5 millions d'entre nous est probablement
moins le double
si on ajoute le nombre estimé de ceux
qui ne sont pas allés se faire tester
faute de symptômes nota oui notre pays
traverse depuis quelques semaines une
phase difficile d'abord à l'hôpital où
la tension reste forte même si la
mobilisation remarquable de nos
soignants a permis jusqu'à présent de
faire face chaque jour à des arrivées
toujours importante de malades mais
également dans notre i quotidienne avec
le nombre spectaculaire des
contaminations dues aux variants
microbes peu de familles ont été
épargnés avec tout ce que cela
occasionne en termes de tests à réaliser
pour les proches de contraintes
d'isolement pour les malades et bien sûr
dans l'oise quand des symptômes
importants apparaissent cette vague
exceptionnelle n'est pas terminé mais je
pense pouvoir vous dire que
l'association commence à évoluer plus
favorable la première évolution positive
est que la vague nier aux variants delta
est partout en net reflux c'est très
important car vous savez que ce variant
delta était plus dangereux que les
variants précédent depuis une semaine le
nombre des malades en réanimation se
réduit enfin légèrement et cette baisse
devrait se prolonger à mesure que le
variant delta poursuivra sa décrue la
deuxième nouvelle encourageante et que
la vague provoquée par le variant
omicron commence à marquer le pas dans
les régions où ce variant avait frappé
en premier à la fin décembre c'est en
particulier le cas en ile-de-france où
la décrue est maintenant engagée
certes ce que nous constatons en ile de
france n'est pas encore vrai dans la
plupart des autres régions
métropolitaines où le variant omicron
est arrivé plus tard et où le nombre de
contamination continuent de progresser
je veux mentionner aussi la situation
particulière des départements et
territoires d'outre-mer qui connaissent
des flambées épidémiques régulière où le
niveau de vaccination est plus bas que
dans le reste du pays ce qui nous a
conduits à proroger où j'ai état de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire
mais cette mais cette évolution
différente selon les territoires et
classique et donc ce qui se passe en île
de france décident une perspective
rassurante et surtout cohérentes avec ce
que l'on observe au royaume uni où la
région du grand londres a connu son pic
dix jours avant le reste du pays la
troisième nouvelle rassurante c'est
enfin la confirmation que ce variant
omicron est certes beaucoup plus
dangereux mais clairement moins sévère
que ses prédécesseurs je sais que cet
élément nouveau a pu conduire à se poser
des questions est-ce que cela sert
encore à quelque chose se faire vacciner
ou de faire son rappel si même vacciné
on peut attraper aussi facilement ce
virus est ce que face à l'ampleur de la
vague il ne faudrait pas tout simplement
laissé filé
l'épidémie sans rien faire ne prendre
aucune mesure de plus se tester en cas
de doute ne plus s'isoler quand on est
positif je vous le dis clairement même
atténuées ce virus n'a rien d'anodin il
ne s'agit absolument pas d'une simple
grippe un seul chiffre pour le démontrer
au cours d'une année normale
l'épidémie de grippe provoque en moyenne
dix mille hospitalisation sur toute la
période de l'hiver avec omicron nous
atteignons ce chiffre non pas en trois
mois mais en cinq jours seulement si
nous avons pu traverser ces dernières
semaines avec des centaines de millier
de contaminations chaque jour et des
hôpitaux qui ont tenu ce n'est pas le
fruit du hasard c'est parce que nous
avons pris les bonnes décisions parce
que nous sommes massivement vacciner et
que nos vaccins restent extrêmement
protecteurs oui les caractéristiques de
ce variant font qu'on peut facilement
attraper le virus a n'étant vacciner
mais là aussi deux chiffres très
parlants une personne complètement
vaccinés à quatre fois et demi moins de
risques d'attraper la co vide et surtout
25 fois moins de risques d'être
hospitalisées en soins critiques c'est à
dire avec des formes graves par rapport
à une personnes non vaccinées
seuls 7% des adultes ne sont toujours
pas vaccinées et pourtant ils
représentent l'écrasante majorité des
patients hospitalisés dans les services
de réanimation au grand dam de nos
soignants qui se battent au quotidien
depuis deux ans de façon admirable
inlassablement je me rends auprès de
auprès des personnels des établissements
de santé j'y serai une nouvelle fois
demain plus encore après demain le
gouvernement déploie dans le cadre du
ségur de la santé des moyens inédits
pour à la fois rattraper le retard
accumulé depuis des décennies et donner
à notre système de soins et à ses
acteurs les perspectives dont ils ont
besoin on ne le dira jamais assez la
vaccination a changé la donne et nous
devons poursuivre nos efforts en dépit
des résultats qui nous place grâce à une
mobilisation exceptionnelle que
l'histoire retiendra parmi les nations
les mieux vacciner et donc les plus
protégés au monde plus de 93 pour ça les
adultes ont reçu leurs premières doses
plus de 91% de dose ou l'équivalent en
plus de 62% trois doses ou l'équivalent
mais nous devons encore poursuivre notre
mobilisation ne devant en particulier
faire progresser la vaccination des
enfants de 5 à 11 ans qui a démarré
doucement même si je sais que beaucoup
de parents hésitent encore je veux leur
dire que les autorités scientifiques
sont très clairs sur le bénéfice de
cette vaccination et nous la
faciliteront 1 autorisant davantage de
lieux et deux professionnels y compris
les pharmaciens et les infirmières à
pouvoir réaliser cette injection pour
les 12 17 ans
l'ouverture du rappel a été décidé pour
ceux qui sont atteints de pathologies
chroniques comme beaucoup de pays autour
de nous l'ont fait je vous annonce que
nous allons étendre cette possibilité
d'un rappel vaccinal pour tous mais sans
obligation à compter de lundi prochain
pour tous les autres nous devons sans
relâche poursuivre notre stratégie
d'aller vers les non vaccinés en
particulier les populations les plus
éloignés du système de soins au delà de
la vaccination notre stratégie de
dépistage et les mesures de freinage
prise le mois dernier ont été tout aussi
utile les simulations de l'institut
pasteur ont montré que si nous n'avions
pris aucune mesure le nombre des entrées
hospitalière au cours de ce mois de
janvier aurait été deux fois plus élevé
je dis bien deux fois plus élevé grâce à
la vaccination
grâce au pass sanitaires nous n'avons
pas eu à prendre des mesures aussi
contraignantes que beaucoup de nos
voisins européens en particulier nous
avons préservé la continuité des
activités nous n'avons pas restaurée de
couvre feu et nous avons fait le choix
de laisser nos écoles ouvertes c'est un
choix fort constant depuis le début de
la crise sanitaire qui repose sur
l'intérêt de nos enfants
j'ai parfaitement conscience que
l'adaptation du protocole sanitaire à
l'école a entraîné des difficultés des
difficultés pour les parents d'élèves
des difficultés pour nos enseignants et
plus généralement pour toutes celles et
ceux qui concourent au service public de
l'éducation et de la petite enfance dans
l'état dans les collectivités
territoriales et dans tous les
établissements accueillant des enfants
je veux leur répéter toute la
considération du gouvernement et de la
nation pour leur engagement et leur
dévouement au service de l'école ouverte
au service des enfants
france avec le ministre de l'éducation
nationale et le ministre de la santé
j'ai reçu les représentants des
personnels de l'éducation nationale et
nous avons apporté les correctifs
nécessaires mais rien n'aurait été pire
que de fermer des établissements
scolaires voire de retarder la rentrée
car la réouverture vu la flambée du
nombre de cas auraient été très
difficile avant-hier mardi
17 mille trente sept classes étaient
fermés c'est beaucoup mais cela
représente
3,2 pour cent des classes en france
3,2 pour cent si comme certains nous le
suggère nous avions fermé 100% des
classes je vous laisse déduire vous même
tout les conséquentes je suis convaincu
que notre choix a été le bon tester
tester pour ne pas fermer d'ester pour
freiner l'épidémie plus de 12 millions
de personnes se sont fait tester la
semaine dernière c'est un record absolu
c'est deux fois plus que lors de toutes
les vagues précédentes et c'est
nécessaire pour freiner au micro ondes
pour le faire reculer il faut d'abord
que les personnes contaminées le sage et
s'isole pour ne pas diffuser le virus
davantage encore c'est la base de la
lutte contre toute épidémie je veux
remercier tous les professionnels qui
ont contribué à cet effort de dépistage
exceptionnelle et qui continue encore et
en particulier les pharmaciens de notre
pays mais aussi tous les acteurs tous
les professionnels qui nous ont permis
d'ouvrir
425 nouveaux centres de dépistage depuis
le début de l'année 2022
c'est également un effort à mettre au
crédit de nos concitoyens qui joue
pleinement le jeu des autotests demandé
aux personnes cas contact avec plus d'un
million d'autotest délivrés
jour dans nos pharmacies
mesdames et messieurs
l'ensemble de ces éléments qui sont le
résultat de nos efforts individuels et
collectifs nous permettent ce soir de
dresser des perspectives
comme toujours nous le faisons de
manière progressive et cohérente
l'évolution de la situation nous permet
d'envisager un allègement des
contraintes dès les premiers jours de
février nous pouvons l'envisager parce
que nous disposerons très bientôt d'un
nouvel outil le pass vaccinale que la
représentation nationale a voté et qui
entrera en vigueur lundi prochain le 24
janvier sous réserve bien sûr de la
décision du conseil constitutionnel
attendu demain
concrètement l'ensemble des français de
16 ans et plus devront justifier d'un
schéma vaccinal complet pour aller au
restaurant au cinéma au théâtre dans un
stade ou pour prendre le tgv sauf pour
les enfants de 12 à 15 ans il ne sera
plus possible de rentrer dans ces lieux
avec un simple test négatif seules les
visites dans les hôpitaux maisons de
retraites ou autres établissements
médico sociaux pourront rester
accessible avec un test comme c'est déjà
le cas aujourd'hui
je rappelle que le schéma vaccinal
complaisent suppose de faire son rappel
dans un délai de sept mois après la
dernière injection et que ce délai sera
ramené à quatre mois à partir du 15
février conformément à ce que nous avons
déjà annoncé fin décembre nous
veillerons à ce que cette évolution ne
pénalise pas à nos français nos
concitoyens de l'étranger qui devront
pouvoir bénéficier rapidement d'une dose
de rappel lorsqu'ils reviennent chez eux
depuis l'annnonce du pass vaccinale plus
d'un million de français qui n'était pas
encore vaccinée ont franchi le pas c'est
bien mais ce n'est pas encore suffisant
il faut amplifier ce mouvement je vous
annonce que nous allons permettre à
celles et ceux qui feront leurs
premières doses d'ici le 15 février de
bénéficier d'un pass vaccinale valide à
deux conditions bien faire leur deuxième
dose un mois plus tard et dans
l'intervalle justifier également d'un
test négatif de moins de 24 heures la
transformation du pass sanitaire en
passe vaccinale est une évolution
nécessaire et cohérente elle est
nécessaire si nous voulons préserver et
amplifier notre couverture vaccinale
aussi bien aujourd'hui que demain en cas
de nouveaux variants elle est cohérente
car elle assume de faire peser
clairement la contrainte sur les non
vaccinés et dès lors de pouvoir lever
les mesures de freinage que nous avons
prises pour contrer la dernière vague
nous allons donc alléger les mesures en
vigueur en deux étapes qui
interviendront les mercredis 2 et 16
février c'est d'élèves devant permettre
le déploiement en bon ordre du pass
vaccinale et à nos hôpitaux d'absorber
les effets du pic épidémique
a compté donc lu mercredi 2 février
tous les équipements notamment sportifs
et culturels qui accueillent du public
assis pour en retrouver un
fonctionnement à pleine capacité san
jose en respectant cependant
l'obligation du port du masque à cette
même échéance le télétravail ne sera
plus obligatoire mais restera recommandé
en laissant aux entreprises de soin de
maintenir le bon niveau dans le cadre de
leur dialogue social interne le port du
masque ne sort plus exigée en extérieur
à compter du mercredi 16 février nous
lèverons les autres mesures la
consommation dans les stades les cinémas
ou les transports sera à nouveau
autorisée les concerts debout et la
consommation debout dans les bars pour
en reprendre les discothèques pour en
rouvrir j'ajoute que nous pourrons aussi
envisagée au retour des vacances
scolaires de février un allègement du
protocole scolaire sur la levée du port
du masque pour les élèves dans les
écoles élémentaires ou sur la question
du nombre de tests ou d'auto tests à
réaliser nous consulterons bien sûr à
cet effet les autorités sanitaires
je sais que cette perspective de reprise
ou d'allégements et est attendu l'
approche graduée et progressive que nous
retenons appelle évidemment de la part
de chacune et chacun un respect strict
des règles du jeu jusqu'à leur terme de
même nous maintiendrons évidemment
jusqu'à ses échéances tous les
dispositifs de soutien économique que
subissent aujourd'hui
l'impact de nos mesures je pense en
particulier aux hôtels cafés restaurants
et traiteurs mais aussi au secteur de
l'événementiel du sport et de la culture
que nous aiderons comme à chaque fois à
passer le cap au delà de quoi l'avenir
sera t-il fait sur le plan sanitaire
cette question appelle forcément à
l'humilité et à la prudence nos
autorités scientifiques ne savent pas
nous dire si le variant omicron marque
une étape décisive sur la voie d'une
banalisation du virus ou bien si nous
restons encore exposés aux risques
qu'apparaissent de nouveaux variants
problématique
mon gouvernement a bien sûr la
responsabilité d'anticiper toutes ces
hypothèses
pour cela la france dispose désormais
d'une gamme complète d'outils que la loi
nous permet d'activer jusqu'à la fin du
mois de juillet cette capacité à agir ne
signifie évidemment pas que nous sommes
tenus d'activer ces mesures de
restriction aussi longtemps que la loi
nous y autorise cela n'aurait aucun sens
il faut savoir réagir vite quand c'est
nécessaire mais il faut aussi savoir
lever les mesures dès que les conditions
permettent de le faire cela vaut aussi
pour le pass vaccinale ça nécessitait je
les dis ne fait aucun doute aujourd'hui
mais je veux être clair le pass pourrait
tout à fait être suspendue si la
pression épidémique et surtout
hospitalière venait à se réduire
fortement et durablement sinon au
service de réanimation ne voyait plus
arriver de nouveaux malades pendant
plusieurs semaines si nos hôpitaux
n'était plus obligé de déprogrammer des
soins si la cites pression sanitaire
redescendre est au plus bas alors nous
serions amenés à lever le pass tout en
nous tenant évidemment prêts à leur est
activé en cas de redémarrage
mesdames et messieurs mes chers
concitoyens voici les orientations et
les perspectives que je souhaitais
partager ce soir avec vous nous sommes
incontestablement dans une nouvelle
phase de l'épidémie grâce à nos efforts
collectifs
grâce à la vaccination nous allons faire
face à la vague en cours nous devons
être confiants tout en restant très
vigilant
respectueux des autres et des consignes
collectives
mobilisés et plus que jamais solidaires
je vous remercie et nous allons
maintenant avec olivier ferrand ministre
des solidarités et de la santé répondre
à vos questions
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur
ministre bonjour l syntaxin pour tf1 et
lci vous annoncé un allègement des
restrictions alors même qu'on parle de
l'arrivée d'un nouveau variant du bea
points 2 plus transmissible comique ron
est déjà présent au royaume uni ne
redoutez vous pas une cinquième vague et
pensez vous tenir coûte que coûte le
calendrier annoncé ce soir et puis vous
avez parlé d'un nouveau protocole dans
les écoles d'allègement après les
vacances quand pouvez vous pensez vous
pouvoir donner ce nouveau protocole et
donc quelle échéance avez vous pour la
lance de ce2 sont vos projets pour
bonsoir oui alors il ya des variants
assez régulièrement
l'om est classe d variant en fonction de
leurs caractéristiques de contagiosité
de dangerosité de risque déjà de
d'échappement à la vaccination le
vaillant auquel vous faites allusion est
un sou vaillant issus de mikron qu'on
trouve essentiellement au danemark on
trouve aussi au royaume uni on l'a
identifié par techniques de séquençage
sur le territoire national pour ce que
nous savons pour l'instant d'ailleurs de
l'om être ne l'a pas classé comme un
variante d'intérêt en tout cas pas à ce
stade pour ce que nous savons il
correspond peu ou prou aux
caractéristiques que nous connaissions
de mikron et il n'y a pas à ce stade de
connaissances sur des risques de
contagiosité vis-à-vis de celles et ceux
qui auraient déjà contracté le variant
omicron dos il ferait partie
pardonnez-moi de la gamme des
sous-groupes du variant mikron et ne
change pas la donne ce qui est
fondamental c'est qu'on est au garde une
surveillance à l'échelle planétaire très
rapprochés via les techniques de
séquençage on fait beaucoup en europe
beaucoup en france un peu moins dans
d'autres pays mais quand même l'afrique
du sud nous a montré qu'elle était
capable de diagnostiquer tôt invariants
comme mikron pour que si un vrai nouveau
variant devait arriver issu d'une
nouvelle souche par exemple avec des
caractéristiques différentes ce que
personne ne souhaite
je vous le dis tout de suite et bien
nous puissions réagir rapidement comme
nous avons été amenés à le faire en
retardant l'apparition de vagues
épidémiques donc on s'inscrit dans une
dans une durée comme le dit le premier
ministre avec des outils qu'on est
capable d'activer lorsqu'il faut le
faire pour freiner coupé mais qu'on est
aussi capable de lever lorsque la
situation nous semble davantage sous
contrôle
il s'agissant de votre
deuxième question je je veillerai à ce
que j'indiquais donc le protocole actuel
va rester en vigueur que nous avons
aménagé adapté dans les conditions que
vous savez sur lesquelles je ne
reviendrai pas jusqu'à sortie des
classes il ya trois zones vous le savez
tout ça et donc nous profiterons de ce
temps pour voir comment les choses
évoluent nous ressaisir enfin qu'olivier
ferrand les autorités sanitaires puisque
je rappelle que les protocoles notamment
s'agissant de la détermination du nombre
de tests pour les cas contacts pour les
enfants en particulier sont déterminés
par les autorités sanitaires nous
renouveler ressaisiront voir dans quelle
mesure à la rentrée
pour quelques semaines devant nous nous
pourrons adapter le dispositif
entre question
va peut-être en 22 ou par la suite comme
on le fait d'habitude pour sa part
monsieur monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur ministre elisabeth lomé pour
bfm tv une précision par rapport à ce
que vous venez de dire monsieur le
premier ministre vous avez dit que le
pass vaccinale pourrait être suspendue
si la pression épidémique se réduisait
sur quels critères sanitaires vous basez
vous est ce qu'il faut est ce qu'il faut
prendre en compte le taux d'incidence le
nombre de contaminations par jour est-ce
que vous avez vous envisagé d'introduire
des seuils est-ce que vous pouvez nous
apporter des précisions sur cette
éventuelle levée du passé ni terre et
j'ai une nouvelle précise du palais
vaccinale pardon et j'ai une nouvelle
précision à vous demander concernant la
levée du protocole dans les écoles en
tout cas son allégement les vacances
sont effectivement en échelonné est ce
que vous envisagez du coup de le lever à
partir de la reprise des cours pour la
première zone donc fin février le 21
février de mémoire où ça sera une mesure
au niveau national qui débutera donc en
mars merci autre question en fin de
droit et on répondra
jauge à la mi-mars au pour la fp pouvez
vous nous expliquer pourquoi vous ne
fixer aucun critère épidémiologique
finalement pour lever les restrictions 2
février au 16 est-ce que tout s'est levé
sont considérées comme acquises
troisième et en réponse au final pas
bonjour l abonné pour essayer tf1 vous
avez parlé de la réouverture des
discothèques à partir du 16 février ce
que le masque le port du masque sera
obligatoire à ce moment là dans les
discothèques
merci dieu ligne plusieurs
compléterait oui et plusieurs questions
pour déposer d'abord sur les indicateurs
des critères pour le pass vaccinale
ce que nous voulons c'est comme l'a dit
le premier ministre que la situation
sanitaire soit stabilisée sous contrôle
que nous voulons c'est qu'il n'y ait
plus de soin des programmes et ce que
nous voulons ce qui n'est pas des
médecins qui sont obligés d'appeler des
familles de malades pour leur dire
qu'elle a s'il n'y a plus de places
disponibles pour pouvoir les opérer en
temps et en heure parce que des lits de
réanimation sont trop nombreux à être
occupés par des patients atteints des
formes graves du co lead le pass
vaccinale est un outil de protection un
outil qui gonfle qui permet de booster
les primo vaccination de notre pays est
un outil qui réduit aussi les risques de
se contaminer dans les endroits dans
lesquels il sera appliqué dès lors que
la pression hospitalière est
suffisamment base nous l'avons connu à
plusieurs reprises dans la fosse était
au mois d'août par exemple je crois que
nous étions descendus même en dessous
des 1000 patients coded en réanimation
il y avait une charge hospitalière qui
s'était réduite et la dynamique
épidémique n'était plus là les taux
d'incidence montré que le virus circule
et à bas bruit mais pas fortement c'est
des moments où on peut en confiance
lever un certain nombre de mesures qui
aujourd'hui vit ça nous protéger et qui
serait jugée disproportionnée par la
population au regard du risque sanitaire
dont est-ce qu'il faut établir des
critères à la lettre l'histoire
nettement de cette pandémie nous a
montré depuis deux ans que la vérité
d'un jour n'est pas forcément celle du
lendemain s'il n'y avait pas de nouveaux
variants une fois que la vague au micro
on était passé nous pourrions nous dire
que nous pouvons à nouveau vivre
tranquillement sans avoir peur
qu'émergent de nouvelles vagues auquel
cas nous serions amenés à relâcher les
mesures de contrainte y compris celles
qui passent par le pacte d'actionnaires
celle inverse il y avait des menaces
épidémie qui se faisait jour on en
parlait tout à l'heure avec votre
collègue il ya quelques minutes s'il y
avait un nouveau variant qui devait
apparaître forcément ça pourrait changer
la donne même si la pression sanitaires
étaient plus faibles donc on appliquera
le pass vaccinale aussi longtemps que
nécessaire mais pas plus autant que
nécessaire de la même manière vous poser
la question pourquoi le 2 et le 7
février je me permets de répondre ces
prémices dans la continuité mais
pourquoi le 2 février
le 2 février ça fera une semaine que le
pass vaccinale sera en vigueur pourquoi
le passage final dans les établissements
qui reçoivent du public les restaurants
les bars les cinémas et bien dès lors
qu'on aura au moins une semaine de
retour on sait que le pass vaccinale
sera bien accepté bien contrôlé bien mis
en place le risque de contamination sera
considérée comme suffisamment faible
pour qu'on puisse relâché aujourd'hui
des mesures restrictives comme les
jauges que par exemple ou d'autres
mesures qui pourront à ce moment là être
abandonné et deux semaines plus tard je
dirais les situations les plus à risque
pourquoi deux semaines plus tard parce
qu'on considère que aux alentours de la
mi février non seulement on devrait
avoir largement passé le pic épidémique
de mikron mais que si on se calque sur
la situation de nos voisins britanniques
par exemple on sera sans doute déjà
descendu beaucoup plus bas en termes de
nombre de contacts de contamination par
jour il a déjà énormément circuler le
variant mikron est ce que nous montre
l'exemple franciliens en ile-de-france
où ça a commencé à baisser c'est que ça
va finir par baisser dans tout le pays
et donc trois semaines de recul on est
un peu plus un peu plus serein pour se
dire qu'on peut relaxer encore d'autres
contraintes et permettre aux gens de
retrouver la vie la plus normale
possible pourquoi pas mangé debout dans
les bars où aller danser dans les
discothèques et sur le masque
sur le masque dans les discothèques nous
verrons s'il ya lieu ou non ça ça
dépendra probablement par exemple de la
situation épidémique au moment où la
décision sera prise véritablement de
rouvrir la discothèque on prendra pas de
risques inutiles l'objectif c'est
permettre aux français profiter des
discothèques l'objectif c'est aussi de
permettre aux patrons du monde de la
nuit qui vont enfin rouvrir les
discothèques d'être sûr de pouvoir le
faire en confiance donc si la situation
sanitaire le permet évidemment on
n'imposera pas le masque si en revanche
on est un peu limite à ce moment-là
peut-être contré amené à le demander de
le conserver encore quelques jours ou
quelques semaines
rappelé à mme via le temps que vous
passiez les micros à ce jour pas la
finalité la philosophie de ses passes et
double je le rappelle à tous nos
concitoyens
elle consiste d'abord à éviter des
mesures de fermeture le pass sanitaires
amy le pass vaccinale encore davantage
et à inciter très fortement à la
vaccination puisque maintenant on
connaît mieux omicron la bonne nouvelle
encore une fois c'est la très forte
décrue de delta dans la dangerosité est
avérée et on sait que avec omicron
quelques dangereux quelques contagieux
pardon qu'il soit nous savons qu'avec un
schéma vaccinal complète notamment trois
doses et forcément comme je vous l'avais
dit le pass vaccinale mallet inciter
encore davantage ce qui reste toujours
la pierre d'achoppement forte
c'est-à-dire les capacités hospitalières
seront moins mobilisés
juste une petite précision sur les
discothèques puisque manifestement c'est
la grande inquiétude des professionnels
un test négatif sur at il demandé lampre
en plus du pack vaccinale
autre question gens venir peut-être
montré par vagues bonjour
merci à nouveau allison tassin pour tf1
et lci vous n'avez pas évoquer la fin du
masque en intérieur est-ce que vous avez
une visibilité là tu es ce que cette ce
port du masque en intérieur pourrait
intervenir avant ou après la fin du pass
vaccinale est ce que l'art est
conditionnée à l'autre merci bien
donc vous vivez sur le site de questions
sanitaires l'une sur le leader je
m'attendais quand vous avez évoqué les
discothèques plutôt que le masque que
vous posiez d'emblée celle sur les tests
qui s'ajouterait donc au pass campion
bien que le passe évidemment pas xidan
sera imposée à l'entrée discothèque donc
à la question parce que ça se pratique
dans certains pays je le dis à celles et
ceux qui l'écoutent d'y ajouter la
nécessité d'un test et puis à la
question du max un extérieur celui mais
il ya deux éléments alors d'abord c'est
ce que vous appelez le pass 2 g + qui le
passe à l'allemande c'est parce
vaccinale plus test depuis moins de 24
heures négatif la loi nous permet de le
faire dans la loi qu'on votait les
parlementaires il est inscrit la
possibilité d'adapter les conditions
d'application du palais national mais
nous n'avons pas l'ambition de le faire
en tout cas pas en l'état nous
considérons que nous pouvons ouvrir et
10 tech avec suffisamment maintenant de
recul face à la menace que constitue
omicron pour pouvoir le faire si jamais
la situation devait évoluer encore une
fois prudents ne ressortait pas la vidéo
dans trois semaines pour dire qu'on
aurait dit inverse on sait jamais ce qui
peut arriver mais telle est l'intention
actuellement est de même pour le masquer
en intérieur le masque en intérieur est
quand même encore une petite protection
nécessaire surtout quand on a beaucoup
de contamination au quotidien quand vous
regardez ce qui se passe à l'étranger on
parle de l'exemple anglais qui est un
peu le groupe contrôle en l'occurrence
parce qu'ils ont levé toutes les
restrictions d'un seul coup mais
regardez l'allemagne quand même beaucoup
plus de mesure aujourd'hui de contrainte
et qui pourraient renforcer parce que
eux sont dans la phase ascendante de la
vague au micro regardez l'italie qui a
mis en place en place un pass vaccinale
à la française d'ailleurs et qui du coup
leur permet à l'instar de ce que nous
faisons de réduire les restrictions mais
regardez d'autres pays les pays bas qui
sont encore en confinement l'autriche
qui en sort tout doucement c'est donc ya
pas il n'y a pas un rythme uniforme sur
tout le territoire européen chacun tire
conséquence de l'expérience acquise de
la situation épidémique et sanitaires au
moment où il prend des mesures nous nous
avons été frappés par une vague delta
plus tardive que nos voisins européens
mais très forte et qui a rempli nos
hôpitaux et qui a rempli nos services de
réanimation c'est pour ça que nous
sommes obligés d'être un peu plus
prudent que certains des voisins qui ont
été touchés très fortement aussi mais
qui ont connu une vague delta plus
précoce et qui a eu le temps de se
réduire avant que la vague au micro de
démarre donc on adapte les choses mais
pour répondre à votre question
aujourd'hui on conserverait le masque en
intérieur on appliquerait pas bac
simpliste est des risques au tac
merci beaucoup dames les messieurs
en soirée
merci à vous d'avoir suivi ce live et
ses annonces de jean castex et olivier
ferrand vous l'avez entendu on va
débriefer fier on va débriefer excusez
moi cette intervention je suis avec
vincent brunelle journaliste science au
figaro vous n'hésitez pas comme
d'habitude à poser vos questions dans le
tchat on essaiera d'y répondre tout en
restant poli dans les commentaires bien
évidemment mais ça vous avez l'habitude
je vais peut-être vous lister juste
avant les mesures qui ont été annoncées
alors des mesures en deux temps d'abord
le 2 février la fin des jeunes et du
masque en extérieur le télétravail qui
devient recommandée est plus obligatoire
et le 16 février l'ouverture des boîtes
des boîtes de nuit des reprises des
concerts debout la consommation possible
dans les stades est debout aussi dans
les bars on parle aussi d'un possible
allègement pour le protocole sanitaire à
la suite de ça dans les écoles mais le
même premier ministre et le ministre la
santé ont voulu rester très prudent
vincent il ya un jean castex qui a dit
aujourd'hui que ces mesures là elles ont
été mises en place grâce au pass
vaccinale pourquoi alors je rajouterais
juste deux éléments dans les mesures
c'est l'ouverture pour le rappel aux
12-17 ans et faciliter le vaccin pour
les les plus jeunes mais on est dans la
même idée oui jean castex a commencé son
allocution en expliquant que si
aujourd'hui on pouvait alléger les les
mesures de restriction c'était pour deux
raisons d'une part parce que le pic de
la vague au micro on devrait arriver
prochainement on l'espère tous et puis
aussi et surtout parce qu'à partir de
lundi la france sera dotée d'un pass
vaccinale alors c'est à dire que à
partir de lundi
le pays va à confiner tous ceux qui ne
sont pas vaccinés toutes les
restrictions s'appliqueront sur sur eux
et contrairement à ce que pouvait être
objective du passé ni terne dont le but
était de réduire voire de freiner
totalement la circulation du virus et
donc de d'empêcher le nombre de cas 2,2
d'exploser là on passe dans une autre
stratégie parce que nouveau variant est
donc variant d'échappement c'est-à-dire
qu'ils contaminent les gens qui ont déjà
été malade et les gens qui ont été
vaccinés on passe dans une stratégie qui
essayent de protéger notre système de
soins et faire en sorte à ce que les
personnes susceptibles de de faire des
formes graves ne puisse pas fréquenter
des lieux à risque autrement dit les
lieux de vie tout simplement donc les
restaurants les boîtes de nuit mais même
les stades et c'était en fait la formule
va sans doute pas plaire mais le but est
de protéger contre eux mêmes les gens
qui ne sont pas vaccinés
l'idée aussi c'est de pousser encore
plus les français à la vaccination jean
castex a parlé d'un million de français
qui se seraient fait vacciner depuis
l'annnonce du pass vaccinale oui parce
que s'il ya plus de 50 millions de
français qui sont vaccinées on a
l'impression qu'on a atteint le plein et
fameux plafond de verre mais on continue
petit à petit a grappillé dans dans ce
réservoir ce que tous les personnes qui
se font pas vacciner il n'y a pas une
homogénéité du de l'opposition en
vaccins il ya beaucoup de personnes qui
qui s'interroge qui doute y en a qui
sont farouchement contre pour des
raisons d fois incontestable des fois -
et donc
le but c'est de convaincre tous ces
indécis que le vaccin peut être utile à
la fois collectivement mais aussi
individuellement
c'est une conviction par la contrainte
donc c'est quelque chose qui est qu'ils
assument et tel quel mais qui force est
de constater fonctionne et continuer à
faire affaire grappiller le
faire qu à faire augmenter le nombre de
vaccinés et objectivement c'est quelque
chose qui a une incidence les modèles
institut pasteur le montrer et puis on
l'a on le constate aussi sur l'analyse
des chiffres passés au n'augmentant
cette couverture vaccinale on limite les
risques de saturation dans nos systèmes
de soins et on va abaisser le niveau du
pic alors on peut répondre que la
protection à une dose n'est pas la même
que la protection à trois doses et donc
le le parcours vaccinale est trop long
pour que pour que ce soit utile on se
rend compte quand même qu'avec une dose
de vaccin on est protégé moins protégées
que quand on a trois doses mais on est
quand même protéger surtout quand c'est
dans le dans le premier mois et donc le
risque individuel et aussi à plus faible
que quand il est passé ces six en tout
cas l'analyse qui est celle du
gouvernement
pourquoi faire des annonces aujourd'hui
maintenant par le gouvernement le
calendrier peut un peu surprendre
sachant qu'on est un peu toujours en
pleine vague du variant omicron et que
le nombre de cas 425 mille cas
aujourd'hui qui ont été annoncées c'est
quand même encore très haut oui il ya
plusieurs raisons une raison très
politique c'est que le pass vaccinale
commence sera mis en place lundi si le
la réserve du conseil constitutionnel
bien bien entendu et ensuite
ça a été dit répété par jean castex si
aujourd'hui on se permet d'envisager une
amélioration en france c'est parce qu'on
a le recul britannique les le royaume
uni est rentré une quinzaine de jours
avant nous dans la vague ou micron a
connu une envolée du nombre de cas
similaires à celles qui a dans le pays
depuis une dizaine de jours maintenant
si je me trompe pas l'incidence et est
nettement retombée la pression se fait
moindre sur le système de soins on a
remarqué une augmentation certes des
hospitalisations mais beaucoup moins
forte au niveau des formes graves et des
admissions dans l'ain dans les soins
critiques et est en réanimation donc
c'est c'est fort de ce bilan que
que con qu'on se rendant dans ce nouveau
dans cette nouvelle étape avec ses
perspectives de début février alors il
se trouve que les indicateurs en france
sont plutôt bons depuis une semaine on
voit que le nombre d'admissions en
réanimation est en baisse et en place
assez franche depuis depuis une semaine
les admissions à l'hôpital continue
d'augmenter mais la hausse est nettement
marquée et semble atterrir sur un sur un
pic sur l'incidence on avait la même la
même dynamique jusqu'à il ya deux jours
maintenant trois jours en comptant
aujourd'hui vu que le nombre de cas est
toujours important on dénomme montre 425
mille tests positifs dans la journée
donc il ya une quelque chose qui s'est
passé à trois jours c'est compliqué de
savoir ce qu'il en est réellement est-ce
que la semaine dernière ont marqué eu
moins de tests effectués un taux de
positivité qui a augmenté donc peut-être
que il ya eu des trous dans la raquette
et dans le dans le système détection ce
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui on aurait une
sorte de rattrapage peut-être que
après on voit aujourd'hui sur les
courbes d'incidence les conséquences de
la rentrée scolaire dia n 10 il ya
quinze jours maintenant c'est en tout
cas ce que semble dire le conseil
scientifique dans son avis rendu public
rendu public mais cette hausse n'est pas
de nature en tout cas à décourager le le
gouvernement au vu de ce qu'ont pu dire
monsieur castex et monsieur les
messieurs vers en
vue que les autres indicateurs restent
positives et c'est je pense l'élément
sur lequel il s'appuie le plus en ile de
france l'incidence est en train de
baisser depuis depuis une trois quatre
jours maintenant c'est la région qui
rentrait en premier dans le variant
micron dont on attend d'avoir un retard
en fait on s'attend à voir un retard par
rapport aux autres exactement c'est ce
qu'on a observés au royaume uni la
région londonienne a commencé à rentrer
dans la décrue une semaine dix jours
avant le reste du pays et le pays a
suivi et donc c'est sur ce schéma là que
se base le gouvernement où j'espère
qu'ils ont raison et que c'est trop se
cache pas autre chose
pour le moment il n'y a aucun élément
pour le savoir
jean castex olivier ferrand ou essayer
d'être très prudent hoguet également
mais on sent qu'ils veulent faire passer
l'idée que c'est peut-être la fin de
cette épidémie de se dire voilà on est
sorti grâce à aux microbes qu'est ce
qu'il en est réellement et c'est encore
beaucoup de jeunes nombre
objectivement on n'en sait rien mais on
a des raisons d'espérer pour pour
résumer on a des raisons d'espérer parce
que on a énormément de personnes qui
sont vaccinées donc protégé contre les
formes graves les vaccins maintienne ses
protections contre les formes gars on
s'en rend compte aujourd'hui avec au
micron qui est moins sévère que que
l'éternel tas mais en termes de risque
individuelle le risque reste quand même
beaucoup plus élevés pour les personnes
qui ne sont pas vaccinés et aujourd'hui
si on permet de si on se permet
d'envisager des d un avenir un peu un
peu un peu meilleur c'est aussi parce
que on a suffisamment de personnes qui
sont vaccinées pour pouvoir absorber
cette vague on me considère que si la
vague ou micron était arrivé si au micro
était arrivé il ya deux ans enfin il ya
un an et demi quand les vaccins étaient
pas été pas là la situation serait
vraiment très très compliqué au vu de la
croissance du nombre de cas
quotidienne y compris y compris celle
sur les formes graves qu'on se concentre
sur les soirées nomades cd donc ça c'est
le premier élément c'est qu'on a cette
couverture actionnable ensuite il ya
cette vague qui est incroyablement
rapide mais qui fait que en l'espace de
une quinzaine de jours d'une douche
plutôt trois semaines entre 5 millions
de personnes ça on en est sûr pas su et
des tests positifs mais on estime qu'une
personne sur deux à peu près et un cas
sur deux arrive à détecter donc entre 5
et 10 millions de personnes ont été
contaminées pendant un point ça perd là
donc on avait une espèce de rappel dax
inhalent
melli par le virus parce qu'ils ont très
peu en développer des formes graves ont
développé des des complications et
auront eu un système militaire qui ont
été boostées naturellement c'est quand
même quelque chose qui est pas qui n'est
pas négligeable et on peut espérer mais
ça malheureusement ce seul l'avenir nous
le dira que les nouveaux variants qui
apparaît seront dans le futur seront de
la même lignée comique rond et donc ne
seront pas tous suffisamment différent
des précédents pour déjouer totalement
notre système immunitaire et faire en
sorte à ce que le virus devient un mythe
c'est encore trop tôt pour le dire parce
que pour le moment les mutations du
sartre comme de donc le virus
responsable du coc vite son sont trop
aléatoire est différente du d'invariants
à l'autre et donc on n'est pas du tout
dans une phase de stabilisation est donc
dans une phase de d'organisation c'est à
dire que le virus circule comme le virus
de la grippe comme les autres comme les
autres coronavirus mais on peut espérer
que ce soit le cas le conseil
scientifique dans son avis rendu public
aujourd'hui
espère donc un retour à la normale des
eaux pour le pour le mois de mars en
termes de wagons micron et évoque le
début de la fin avec bien entendu les
limites c'est à dire que si un variant
apparaît dans un lignage totalement
différent et donc vraiment différent nos
micros ont dû y aura un certain nombre
de questions à se poser qu'il faudra
surveiller etc mais en tout cas
chaque jour qui passe on est mieux armé
on a d une couverture vaccinale une
couverture par les médiations par
l'immunité naturelle qui est importante
puisque si on a des traitements qui
commencent à arriver qui feront que on
pourra limiter les formes graves et
c'est comme ça l'enjeu de 2,7 de cette
pandémie maintenant plus personne ne
croit à
éliminer totalement le virus mais il
faut apprendre à le gérer et donc
limiter les formes graves de la maladie
et sa rentrée ce qu'on arrive à mener
dans les mois à venir et à le rendre
endémique en fait c'est tout à leur
gabarit tout à l'heure un peu rapidement
du côté de l'hôpital des réanimations le
conseil scientifique estime que la vague
va continuer à avoir un impact élevé sur
l'hôpital qu'à la mi mars donc pour
l'hôpital on entame une lente décrue
mais ça va rester pas s'arrêter tendue
jusqu'à la mi mars c'est très compliqué
de réussir à se matérialiser je trouve
c'est que on peut regarder l'avenir avec
une certaine sérénité
mais ça veut pas dire que les choses
vont bien aujourd'hui on a quatre cinq
semaines conseil scientifique dit
jusqu'à jusqu'à la mi mars même très
difficile à passer pour pour le système
de soins qui va continuer à avoir
arriver un certain nombre de malades je
cherchais je cherchais noter les
chiffres avant de monter mais on a quand
même 3200 personnes qui sont
hospitalisés chaque jour et ce chiffre
est en hausse contrairement réanimation
dont le chiffre est en baisse on et a330
ce qui veut dire que il voyant une
inversion contrairement à ce qu'on a pu
connaître jusqu'à maintenant où la
pression était vraiment sur le système
de réanimation je vais services de de
soins de soins critiques là la pression
d'un s'inverser va être plus sur
l'hospitalisation quotidienne forte
heureusement
les cas graves liés au micron sont
beaucoup moins graves qui avec les
anciens variant donc la durée de séjour
et est plus courte ce qui fait que même
si plus de personnes arrivent chaque
jour la pression sera pas comparable à
ce qu'on a pu connaître lors des vagues
précédent mais elle va continuer à être
là c'est vraiment s'ajouter à sa bien
entendu le pardon vont s'ajouter à sa
bien entendu les virus de l'hiver la
grippe etc et puis comme on continue à
vivre et c'est une très bonne chose tous
les accidents de la vie de tous les
jours dans un système qui vit
sous une pression immense depuis depuis
maintenant deux ans donc bien entendu ça
va rester très difficile il faut faut
quand même l'avoir en tête comme dans
les commentaires du figaro on à jean
paul ii qui nous dit il est probable
qu'on doive porter des masques sur le
long terme ça jean castex en a parlé à
une question sur le masque en intérieur
d'ailleurs autant on veut on a eu des
informations sur le masque en extérieur
mais effectivement sur le marché
intérieur ça risque d'être long oui mais
on n'en sait rien si je ne peux pas
répondre sur ça parce que ça va vraiment
dépendre du pour le coup le masque
répond à des indicateurs précis de
circulation épidémique parce que c'est
quand même un objet qui est extrêmement
utile pour limiter les risques dans les
lieux clos qui sont mal aérée et c'est
ce qui est probable c'est que le le
masque soit encore dans nos poches et
deux sur nos visages dès qu'on est dans
des dans des milieux dans un milieu
fermé
jusqu'au printemps voire avoir allaité
mais je vous dis ça sans s'en remettre
sans avoir aucune certitude et on va je
pense qu'il va falloir quand même avoir
un peu d'intelligence et adapter ces
mesures à la situation épidémique c'est
à la fois la pression sur les hôpitaux à
la fois la circulation du virus il va
falloir utiliser les indicateurs comme
des jauges comment on peut le faire sur
sur certains éléments dont le masque en
extérieur par exemple est permis quand
le nombre de cas flambent alors après il
ya tout une question sur l'utilité du
masque à l'extérieur parce que le bien
est reporté honnêtement ça sert à rien
de porter un enfant portait un masque
quand on marche dans la rue n'a aucune
utilité mais à ce moment là on utilise
un indicateur pour pourcel mesures qui
peuvent dans sa moitié pour le coup on
peut quand même espérer que si le nombre
de cas est réduit à
peau de chagrin à partir du mois de mars
à avril on adapte le dispositif pour
pour pour pour limiter la propagation du
virus et donc le port du masque à
l'intérieur mais bon on a su
malheureusement je lis pas dans le marc
de café et on n'a aucune aucun moyen de
savoir comment circuler un virus une
fois que la vague ou micron sera passée
oui puisqu'il peut y avoir d'autres
varions le rappelle est justement
nouveaux variants jean castex en a parlé
ce nouveau variant de mikron qui n'est
pas encore référencé comme variante
dangereux a priori mais c'est une chose
qui arrive avec avec ses variantes qui
apparaissent au jour le jour ou deux
mais on l'a dit des variants n'a assez
régulièrement un virus une fois qu'il
est dans l'organisme il va se répliquer
et à force de se répliquer alors
quelques erreurs dans ses explications
ce qu'on appelle les mutations et
certaines de ces mutations vont lui
donner une caractéristique différentes
ce qu'on appelle un invariant pour le
moment donc il ya un certain nombre de
variantes qui ont été ciblés par par l'
oms comme étant des variants d'intérêt
d'autres des barrières d'inquiétude ces
cas du variant anglais alpha du variant
indien delta un brésilien gama
sud-africain meta est le deuxième
variante sud africain qui est le variant
micro auxquels on fait face aujourd'hui
ces variantes sont considérés
d'inquiétude parce qu'ils sont beaucoup
plus contagieux que les soit de variants
parce que les produits soient plus de
formes graves sont loin de former graves
comme ça par coup soit parce qu'ils
procurent produisent plus de femmes le
kck avec delta c'est pas le cas avec
avec au micro mais dans leur
comportement il ya quelque chose qui va
faire basculer les piles et pour le
variant b12 si je me souviens bien du du
nom il se trouve que c'est invariant qui
est très proche de micron l'a appelé au
micron 2
un moment qui est dominant il me semble
au danemark bah c'est pas le cas au
royaume uni au danemark
l'épidémie au micro on est toujours en
train de progresser contrairement au
royaume uni est ce que c'est à cause de
ce variant c'est difficile de savoir
pour le moment il n'y a pas d'éléments
qui permettent de montrer qu' il serait
beaucoup plus contagieux il est
peut-être un peu plus mais pour comparer
si vous avez une voiture qui roule à 90
une hausse qui roule à 95 à côté vous
voyez pas vraiment la différence que les
deux circule ensemble quoi est donc dans
une contexte où c'est le variant micron
qui circule largement dans le pays on ne
dénote pas une trajectoire différente
avec ce variant là et de ce qu'on voit
aussi il n'ya pas de comporte a priori
je peux me tromper enfin on peut trouver
parce qu'on n'a pas les éléments qui
permettent d'en être sûr mais à priori
il n'y a pas de différend sur la la
gravité de ce variant par rapport au
micro donc c'est quelque chose à
surveiller comme comme le sont tous les
variants mais
on n'est pas dans le contexte dans
lequel on était il ya au début du mois
novembre contre apparu le variant micron
qui pour le coup a tout de suite alerté
la communauté scientifique on à kriss
kross dans les commentaires qui nous dit
comme tout virus plus le variant est
contagieux - il est mortel et en gros il
va se transformer en rhume et s'attendre
tout seul que quelque part est-ce que ça
c'est une règle pour les pour les virus
est ce que le but des virus et pas de
dettes plus contagieux mais moins
létales cas alors c'est pas une règle
tout simplement parce que surtout avec
le sar skov 2 qui est contagieux avant
l'apparition des symptômes donc les
éléments qui vont agir pour la sélection
naturelle et pour favoriser un certain
nombre de parts de variants vont arriver
avant que ne s'exprime le caractère
pathogène et donc dangereux ce qui va
sélectionner le virus est pas si il va
laisser les gens en vie ou s'il va les
tuer parce qu'il est il es tu sûr sur le
long terme par contre ce qui est vrai
c'est que plus un virus circule plus
notre système immunitaire individuel et
collectif est habitué à ce virus et donc
est protégé et donc ce n'est pas tant le
virus qui devient moins dangereux que la
population qui devient le mieux protégé
et c'est pour ça qu'un nouveau virus est
toujours extrêmement dangereux et plus
il est contagieux puis est dangereux
parce que il va contaminer énormément de
personnes en un laps de temps très court
et donc y aura plus de formes graves à
plus de plus de pneumonie dans le cas
d'un virus comme com com com comme les
coronavirus que dans le cas des virus
respiratoires parce que les gens ne
m'ont pas les outils nord système
immunitaire pour le convaincre de partir
au moment où le virus a largement
circulé ce qu'est le cas maintenant du
sari code 2d système immunitaire on est
en plus avec la vaccination ont les
outils pour si ce n'est le bloquer
totalement
l'empêcher de
faire trop de dégâts à notre organisme
très bien merci en tout cas vincent d'en
avoir débriefer toutes les annonces et
nous d'avoir donné cette ses éclairages
scientifiques sur ce qui se passe je
rappelle votre livre comme idée neuve
vérités et légendes merci également à
raphaël en régie merci à vous d'avoir
été très nombreux à nous suivre sur le
site du figaro et sur youtube d'ailleurs
si vous êtes sur youtube n'hésitez pas à
vous abonner pour suivre nos prochains
direct et voilà je vous remercie une
nouvelle fois et je vous dis à bientôt
pour de nouveaux lives sur figaro live
convoi